[Music]
i'm
often drawn to very generic materials as
a starting point for my work i think
because they have
a very easy entry point things feel
immediately identifiable in some way
um there's a material resonance i think
that
people feel that they understand what it
is
and
and in a way that
easy entry then i feel opens up the
possibility of
metaphors kind of expanding out from
them
the first time i started using
the materials that are in this
exhibition the
the pieces that look like figures i call
these forms slumps because they're sort
of these figurative forms that depend on
a hard structure of some kind to support
them an armature
and their way of thinking about
the relation between
the body and um and the support systems
that hold up the body
as a kind of code event codependent
relationship
and i was particularly interested in
foam as the kind of base material for
these
slumps because it is a material that's
used it's a sort of cheap bed
material the other material in this
exhibition of course is are the
emergency blankets
they are
of course
materials that are used to keep people
warm
it's it has a kind of protective
element to it
but when
stretched it also turns into a kind of
two-way mirror
i'm
interested in that and how as people
walk in front of and behind this
vertical plane
they are hidden and revealed
from each other
they are reflected again into the space
and sometimes into each other because
it's a two-way mirror and it also
presents the sculpture
through reflection
in this rounded form
so there are a variety of formal and
conceptual reasons that are always
working together in my material choices
and i'm always thinking about these
different
sort of
layers of the space vertically
and in this exhibition there are
hanging um
water bottles
that are sort of at mid-level they're
kind of at eye level um
they are these uh i think of them as
extensions of the body they're water
bottles so they are used to carry water
which you drink
to um to kind of
replenish your own water but i've also
been interested in how
day laborers and people who again are
don't have space don't have a bathroom
to go to often will use that same bottle
to
urinate and so it becomes this
receptacle for bodily fluids as well and
and so in a way it's a and it's a size
of a head and it hangs at head height so
i think of them as again bodily
at this at the height of a person
standing
and then finally these exit signs or
pieces that are quite high up on the
wall and force people to look up
they're also hung in a way where from
any
given point you can
at best see one side of an exit sign and
so you have to move through the space to
see
the two words on any given sign and so
the movement of
the viewer is an important part of the
piece things are hidden and revealed as
you walk through the space
in this current show and in previous
shows i've used text in different ways
here it's
through these what i think of as
two-word poems in a way these exit signs
that
i think help people
contextualize
the work
gives people anchors through which to
enter the work rather than
provide a kind of descriptive
entry point
so
for example let's see grape grove the
title of the exhibition
which is also an exit sign
in the in the exhibition
um
was a way of thinking about
this moment that we're living through
the pandemic
as a moment that is of course one that
reminds us of our mortality we're
confronted constantly with death
but last spring um
there was this moment when
the sort of the
seasons changed in new york and plans
started to kind of grow out of the
sidewalk cracks and there was something
quite beautiful about this
rebirth
within a city
a rebirth not so much of the people but
of this other
life form these plants and particularly
plants that
are not considered valuable to humans
that are considered weeds but that
irrespective of our desire to have them
around they thrive and they
come back every year
[Music]
you